[Music]
amen amen thank you for that addendum
elder skeet
so we have covered what the resurrection
is its purpose and you have already
stated that there will be two general
resurrections the resurrection of the
just and of the unjust and created when
they take place
the resurrection of the just at the
coming of jesus christ and the
resurrection of the unjust after the
millennium that's right
are there exceptions to this in other
words have resurrections already taken
place in the bible
yes they have
uh lazarus was resurrected but he died
again you see
uh the widow of nay in luke seven her
son was resurrected from the dead but of
course he died again
uh elijah is a widow's son elijah is
someone said paul raised someone uh
uticus peter raised someone but they all
died again the resurrection we were
talking to is the resurrection from
which there will never be any return to
the grave this is a resurrection to
enjoy eternal life without interruption
life with christ so yes they have been
resurrections before but they are not
the resurrection spoken out in uh john
14 1-3 let not your heart be troubled
even god believe also in me i go to
prepare a place for you if i go i will
come again
this i will come again is that general
resurrection
where the the just shall receive the
reward and a thousand years later the
wicked shall be raised to receive theirs
which is total punishment
now there was also a resurrection in
matthew 27 from verse 50. this is a
special resurrection and let me pray
again before i continue lord continue to
instruct me as i speak in jesus name i
pray amen
matthew 27 50 jesus when he had cried
again with a loud voice yielded of the
ghost and behold the veil of the temple
was rent entwined from the top to the
bottom and whole earth did quake and the
rocks rang and the graves were open and
many bodies of sense that slept awoke
arose and came out of the graves after
his resurrection and went into the holy
city and appeared to many matthew 27
50-53 there was a special resurrection
when jesus rose and those people when he
went back up to heaven uh
40 days later he uh he took them with
him that's why we read in ephesians
chapter four
first aid wherefore he saith
when he ascended upon high he led
captivity captive they were captive to
the graves he released them and he took
them with him now they also represent
what the bible calls the first fruits
in first corinthians 15 reading from
verse 19 the bible said if in this life
only we have hope in christ we are of
all men most miserable verse 20 but now
is christ risen from the dead and has
become the first fruits of them that
slept but along with christ are those
who came up with him all together they
represent the first fruits now the first
fruit was one of the seven annual feasts
and i hope i'm not saying too much but
the first fruit was one of the seven
annual feasts the jews the israelites
were required to to keep
they're in order of their occurrence one
the pastor and all seven are found in
leviticus chapter 23 first one passover
second one feast of 11 bread third one
feast of first fruits the fourth feast
of wheat which in the new testament is
called pentecost the fifth one the feast
of trumpets the sixth day of atonement
and adventists know very well about the
day of atonement and the last one was
the feast of tabernacles celebrating
finally our entrance into god's kingdom
now if we look at these number one and
two leviticus 23 reading from verse five
the bible said in the 14th day of the
first month at even
is the the passover
the lord's passover verse 6 and on the
16th day of the same month is the feast
on the 15th day of the same month is the
feast of unleavened bread unto the lord
seven days you must eat 11 bread in the
first day is unholy convocation he shall
do no survivor therein but he shall
offer an offering made by flying to the
lord seven days in the seventh day is
unholy convocation he shall do not
survive work therein now if we look
carefully at verse five and for six in
verse five we have the fourteenth day
in verse six we have the fifteenth day
which means we have two days
look at verse five of leviticus 23
in the fourteenth day of the first month
and even
is the lord's passover that's day one
now we know the passover represents the
sacrifice of christ
because in first corinthians chapter
five verse seven the bible says the last
part of that verse for even christ our
passover is sacrificed for us calvary is
the passover fulfilled and so the
passover which began the same night they
left egypt commemorates the departure
from egypt and represent the deliverance
from the land of sin the passover
represents the death the sacrifice of
christ it occurred on the 14th day of
the of the first month now the very next
day was the first day of the feast of 11
bread which ran for seven days but the
first day of those seven were treated
like a sabbath he shall do no service
therein the bible says in a verse seven
of uh six on seven of leviticus 23
christ died on a friday which actually
was a fulfillment of um leviticus 23 the
very next day was the sabbath a literal
sabbath you see now in this in the in
the feast time the ceremonial sabbath
could fall any day of the week but when
christ died the next day was the literal
sabbath that's why it was called a high
sabbath because it was both the
creation sabbath and the ceremonial
service was called the high sabbath then
the very next day is when the first
fruits were waved before the lord that
first fruit represents the harvest that
was to come
which god would accept now it was
brought to the priest and the priest
would accept it for the people jesus
went up with those who brought from the
grave to present himself and them to god
that god might accept them as a way of
saying i will also accept the larger
harvest to come and so the resurrection
of christ on the third day is typified
in the feast of passover or passover but
unless and bread which began the very
next day after passover which was the
sabbath the seventh day of that
celebration was also settled and that's
a lot i'm trying to tell you at the
moment but that's where the resurrection
of christ is symbolized because paul
says in first corinthians 15 3 and 4
for i have delivered unto you first of
all that which i also received how that
christ died for our sins according to
the scripture and that he was buried and
that he rose again the third day
according to the scripture well where
does the scripture say he would rise the
third day you put in one and one
together you get two you realize in the
ceremony of the first fruit we have the
rising of christ
on the third day the same way the first
fruits were waved on the third day in
the old testament and so christ was the
first fruit those who came up with him
in matthew 27 50 to 53 they were part of
that first fruit and jesus took them to
heaven with him
a long response i hope someone got
something out of that
amen that was very rich elder skeet and
you made that connection so clear in
fact brother waldron is here saying oh
yes that special resurrection is quite
intriguing and oh yes that sabbath was a
high saddle
and uh a brown is asking us to repeat
the bible text that was quoted i believe
that was leviticus
three start reading from verse five
there you go so leviticus 23 from verse
five and you know i really like how you
how you made it clear how the
resurrection was spoken of and even
preached in the old testament because as
i was preparing for this q a i opened up
my concordance to look for the word
resurrection right and i found that the
the word resurrection itself is not
stated in the old testament right
it's only stated verbatim in the
new testament but we know that it still
was preached and we see it in sanctuary
services and many other uh
characters in the bible like job
and even the book of daniel but i think
the word faith is only found but twice
in the old testament so it's very
word faith and the just shall live by
faith is almost never found in the hotel
i think once or twice that's it
it does not mean it doesn't exist you
just have to study and you'll find it
right there in your face it's right
there
amen amen